en las noches mi familia acostumbra
meter al perro para que no pase frío
pero no queremos que muerdan nuestras
cosas mientras dormimos así que diseñe
un sistema lo único es que no sé muy
bien cómo calcularlo espero que puedas
ayudarme la habitación donde lo dejamos
es rectangular muy parecida a ésta y
como las esquinas tenemos muebles con
cosas que puede tirar y morder su correa
no podría llegar hasta ahí pensé en una
correa amarrada al centro de la
habitación para que se pueda mover sin
alcanzar las esquinas pero sólo se
movería en un área muy pequeña así que
se me ocurrió en elipse que abarque la
mayor parte de la habitación de esta
manera no alcanzarían las esquinas y se
podría mover prácticamente por todo el
lugar pero cómo hacer que la cuerda
genere una elipse aquí es donde entra el
mecanismo que diseñé
investigando sobre las elipses descubrí
que no tienen un centro como tal sino
dos pocos pero no de los eléctricos son
dos puntos que mantienen una relación
con la distancia hacia el perímetro esto
significa que la suma de la distancia de
cada uno hacia algún punto de la elipse
siempre será la misma por ejemplo si de
un foco a un punto hay tres metros de
distancia y para el otro foco hay ocho
quiere decir que once metros será una
constante aunque movamos el punto
si en otra parte de la elipse la
distancia es de 6 para el otro foco
habrá 5 porque tiene que sumar 11
el foco se encuentra al trazar una línea
que vaya del eje menor al eje mayor y
que mida la mitad de la distancia entre
el centro y un extremo del eje mayor los
focos son simétricos así que hacemos lo
mismo del otro lado y ya tenemos los dos
focos que tiene la elipse quiere decir
que se amarró un extremo de la correa a
cada foco mi perro estará todo el tiempo
a una distancia fija de la orilla si
caminar alrededor la correa se estiraría
y trataría el contorno de la elipse
porque se acorta la distancia a un punto
pero se alarga la que hay desde el otro
puedes estar tranquila porque nunca
alcanzará las esquinas y tendrá toda
esta área para moverse y no sentirse
encerrado
si quisiera trazar una elipse igual en
otra habitación sólo tengo que calcular
con la fórmula la fórmula general de las
elipses es x cuadrada / a cuadrada más
10 cuadrada / b cuadrada igual a 1 la a
corresponde a la distancia del centro al
punto más alejado sobre el eje x por eso
en la fórmula la a está relacionada con
la equis y la b es la distancia del
centro al punto más alto es decir sobre
el eje y entonces sólo es cuestión de
medir estos segmentos en la habitación
son 4 en la parte más larga desde el
centro a la orilla y 2 metros para la
medida del centro a la parte más angosta
los sustituimos en la fórmula la a por
el 4 y la b por el 2 y nos queda x
cuadrada entre 16 más de cuadrada entre
4 es igual a 1 con esto podemos
construir una elipse idéntica aunque se
te olviden las elipses y sus focos
basta con que mires el sol para
recordarlo porque literalmente el sol es
uno de los focos rodeados por las
elipses de los planetas es el único foco
de elipse que si se ilumina